mais là ça relève peut-être du domaine
de la création pourquoi pas et c'est là
où on retombe alors sur les activités
autres de joël bat donc qu'il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup de cordes à son arc on
va revenir sur la poésie parce que donc
on va vous écouter chanter alors comment
c'est venu cette chanson vous nous
l'avez dit mais il fallait quand même
avoir une voix après il fallait ça vous
avez toujours chanté non non mais là je
il ya un album qui va sortir je prends
des mois de septembre et le 45 tours à
l'avant-première dans les jours qui vont
venir est bon surtout juste sont les mes
poèmes jeux les jeux les 10 mais ils ont
été mis en musique par claude vallois
basso va c'est le laser d'une rencontre
après un match et puis une idée qui a
germé puis c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à
faire des réaliser des rêves
il n'ya pas complètement un des hasards
seulement écouter on vous écoute
maintenant chanter
joël bats donc solide solitude joël bats
ans
je me suis écrit deux lettres hier soir
histoire de voir comment va la vie pour
gilles entend rester assis sur un
trottoir
maladroit sans doute
ce sont les étoiles qui me souffler les
premiers
vite
je pense qu'on peut se tutoyer entre
nous depuis le temps qu'on fait tout
les 400
tu sais j'ai trouvé fatigué l'autre nuit
à la sortie du stade
stomp a rappelé
faut dire que tu avais pas plus mal
à fantasmes ballon à ce tir détourné
j'ai voulu tout fait à l'envers
ce temps d'oublier
refusé
c'est parti
tout seul
j'ai rencontré nathalie au café les
thiols paraît que ça va pas très fort
entre vous deux tu les fais des
reproches
tu as trouvé vieux jeu
ce n'est pas toujours grand jeu c'est
bourré
tu veux un conseil
centre de tall et cher
regardez l'arrivée
écoute là dormir dérange le silence qui
la fondent en souffrir
je te connais trop bien ce sera
difficile
j'écris j'écris mais je sais que cette
lettre jamais tu ne le recevra
j'ai lâché ma stylos papier dérivés dans
le caniveau
mais
je me suis écrit une lettre et un soir
histoire de voir comment va la vie pour
moi
à
elsa
sans toi
joli voilà michel galabru joël bats
merci bien joël bats pour cette carte
blanche samedi